this is cat grant reporting live for GBS
from the Markovian royal palace mehta
human trafficking is an international
scourge children and teens are being
abducted the way our daughter was we
have confirmation on multiple worlds
Earth's metahumans are being deployed by
the enemy as weapons of mass destruction
Intel was on the money Oracle it's
definitely another metahuman trafficking
lab let's shut him down
[Music]
I fear our operation may have been
compromised
welcome to the jungle
[Music]
food proof that's annoying we are on a
mission in space just like the Justice
League let's run it again we might want
a note
we just want to leave your trespass must
be punished wrong answer
[Music]
Young Justice Outsiders premiering
January 4th only on DC Universe
hey everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of new Young Justice season 3
footage to break down and a reminder
about the premiere date so I'll remind
everybody about the schedule at the end
of the video they also dropped a preview
of a special new enhanced edition of the
original Young Justice episodes with
commentary that they're doing in a bunch
of extra stuff so I'll play a clip from
that too later in the video we're doing
a giveaway for IMAX gift certificates
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video but you start with footage of them
in markovia it seems like Terra has been
stolen by the light as part of their
metahuman trafficking ring
Terra Markov of Teen Titans fame is the
Terra from the Judas contract storyline
so obviously Young Justice is doing
something a little bit different with
the characters because her brother geo
force is also in the trailer but that
provides the reason for Nightwing
Artemis Black Lightning in Superboy to
go to markovia to rescue these people so
you get a scene of cat grant
interviewing everyone doing the newscast
then you see Nightwing steam breaking
into the area where they're kept rescue
them that probably provides some of the
path to geo force and the other
characters joining their team and
helping them take down the metahuman
trafficking ring but the set up that
Wonder Woman gives is essentially the
light is working with Darkseid to Col
Earth's metahumans to help them
proliferate maybe with their evil soda
or other consumer products to get the
metahuman gene to start activating in
everyone then steal them and use them to
conquer other worlds in the universe so
that's why Wonder Woman is saying that
Earth's metahumans have been detected on
other planets because the light and dark
side are using them in their army to
conquer the universe
you get a scene of katana Batman and
Metamorpho jumping out of the plane onto
an island that looks like the light is
operating from they get attacked by
Deathstroke you get a funny scene with
metamorphose powers just showing you
some of the things that he can do he
could do way more than that as his name
implies Metamorpho he can change into a
bunch of different types of things so
why we see it's Young Justice you're
gonna see a bunch of notable villains
showing up on Team Light Deathstroke and
count vertigo among them so that's where
you get that count vertigo clip I think
our operation has been compromised
because it's been dismantled by
Nightwing's team based on the way they
cut the footage they make it sound like
count vertigo was behind
kidnapping of Tara but we don't know if
she's gonna be getting her powers this
season but you see them talking to her
brother who's geo force then later in
the trailer you see him look like he's
hooking out like he doesn't know how to
control his powers and he uses his lava
based ability Superboy and Nightwing
freak out then they play it for comedy
because he doesn't have any of his
clothes because he burned them off with
his lava powers so I think that's more
the idea that the light is helping
activate the meta-gene and everyone all
over the planet and geo force just
hasn't learned about his powers yet this
is like one of the first times that he's
tried to use them you get a clip of Bart
Allen in his new Kid Flash costume with
cassie sandsmark Wonder Girl on a
mission to another planet where forager
is from he's from the new gods comics
he's the character that looks kind of
like the turtle that has the armadillo
type powers most of the big fights that
you see later in the trailer are from
that planet like they cut back and forth
between a couple of different battles
but a lot of them take place on whatever
world this is where forager is from
there's a separate scene of Nightwing
talking about running some drill again
maybe he's training a bunch of new
metahumans like geo force or any of the
other people that join the team during
the season you can't really tell who's
standing on the cliff base behind
they're watching them but it's probably
just a couple of the other members of
the team you have that same team of
Nightwing Superboy black lightning in
Artemis trying to plow through one of
the new villains separately another
scene of him and one of his other people
using their armadillo powers to smash
one of the villains as they try to
escape that same villain that Nightwing
was trying to fight earlier separately
you get a shot of halo using her powers
she's one of the new characters she's
from the outsiders in the comics like
they're calling season 3 Young Justice
outsiders because a lot of the new
characters are from Batman in the
outsiders comic book but also because of
the way they're operating outside of the
law halo is one of those new characters
as you can see she has light-based
abilities the different abilities that
she has are denoted by different colors
of light so if she gives up purple light
it's a different power from the yellow
light we get our first shot of Blue
Beetle in a long time fighting one of
the villains on foragers world Tim Drake
in his new costume fighting Clayface
everybody gets a bit of a costume
upgrade mostly because it's cool and
because some time has passed and they
want to update things but then you get
another new shot of a spaceship that
seems like it's helping the Young
Justice characters escape that same
villain that they were all
fighting on foragers world or wherever
this planet is then one last shot of
Artemis punching the frame right into
camera but just a reminder that all
these episodes are dropping Friday
January 4th the Titans finale is
supposed to be Friday December 21st so
they're just taking the week of
Christmas off then after New Year's
everything comes back and this is the
schedule if it looks like Young Justice
is only gonna be on for a little while
it's only because they're airing the
first 13 episodes in 3 episode blocks
once per week so it's 26 episodes for
season 3 but they're just breaking it
into two halves the other big thing that
they just announced they were doing they
released a preview clip for it that I'll
play in a second was enhanced editions
of the original Young Justice episodes
so it involves a bunch of extra
commentary with the artists and the
people that have worked on the comics
I'll just play a clip from that here so
here we go I am Greg Weisman welcome to
the first two episodes of Young Justice
warning upfront we will be spoiling
stuff from seasons 1 and 2 but nothing
from season 3 bill Barossa lead
character designer for seasons 1 and 2
uh hi I'm Jason Spisak and I believe I
play Kid Flash in these two episodes I'm
Brandon V Eddy I'm one of the other
producers on the show
look it's Phil Barossa BBQ I'm the first
one to die in Young Justice
enjoying family time there it is there
we go
now is frozen toast yeah we've gotten
that out of the way and that became a
tradition I think he'll became a victim
in the first episode of season 2 as well
really yeah yeah I was the kroloteans
had me in a some sort of prison alright
yeah Phil is the champagne bottle that
we break over the top of every new
season basically it's sort of to echo
the suffering events that you have
that's it and the labor that's right in
creating this lovely thing what
suffering so as you can see it's a
little bit like an enhanced version of a
commentary track but I'm assuming
they're doing this for some or most of
the original season 1 season 2 Young
Justice episodes and then eventually
maybe season 3 but hopefully if this
works out and people like it they'll do
it for some of the other more popular TV
shows like Titans or something else and
don't forget that Donna Troy Wonder Girl
is premiering on Young Justice with this
new episode coming on Friday so I'll do
a video for her and all the Wonder Woman
stuff that the TV show is doing when
that airs no worries new flash episode
posting later tonight click here for
that new Elseworlds
trailer video and click here for my
brand new infinity war Thor Stormbreaker
deleted scene video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]